this video will help you understand what
a stroke is and the risk for having one
normally blood vessels called arteries
carry blood to the brain the brain needs
a constant flow of blood to get the
oxygen and nutrients it needs to work
properly
during a stroke also known as a brain
attack blood flow to part of the brain
has stopped the most common type of
stroke is called ischemic stroke it can
happen in an artery where a fatty
substance called plaque has made the
artery narrow in one type of ischemic
stroke called a thrombotic stroke the
plaque can break apart and form a blood
clot that blocks the flow of blood to
the brain
in another type of ischemic stroke
called an embolic stroke a blood clot
forms in another area of the body and
travels through the blood stream if it
reaches an artery near or in the brain
it can block the flow of blood when an
artery to part of the brain is blocked
during a stroke oxygen and nutrients in
the blood can't get to those brain cells
the cells start to die within minutes
a less common type of stroke is called a
hemorrhagic stroke it occurs when a
weakened blood vessel breaks open and
leaks blood into the brain this blocks
blood flow to the brain and the leaking
blood puts pressure on the brain tissue
which damages it
in a transient ischemic attack or TIAA a
clot blocks the flow of blood to the
brain but it's different from the other
types of stroke because the clot breaks
up after a short time transient ischemic
attacks usually don't cause any
permanent damage
high blood pressure is the main risk
factor for any type of stroke other risk
factors include diabetes
certain types of heart disease
smoking
high cholesterol
and having previous transient ischemic
attacks
it's important to know these signs and
symptoms of a stroke a sudden numbness
or weakness in your face arms and legs
especially if it's on one side of your
body sudden confusion and trouble
speaking or being unable to understand
others speaking sudden trouble seeing
out of one or both eyes sudden dizziness
loss of balance or being unable to walk
and a sudden severe headache
call 911 or someone else may be having a
stroke
to find out more about your risk for
having a stroke talk to your healthcare
provider